welcome back to cbs this morning
researchers say most terrorist attacks
in the u.s this year
were committed by white supremacists and
like-minded groups
the fbi's most recent statistics on hate
crimes released just last month
show 2019 was the deadliest year on
record
but in a new twist a cbs news
investigation uncovered
that organizations viewed by some as
hate groups
are actually receiving financial
benefits from the federal government
chief investigative correspondent jim
axelrod has been looking into this jim
good morning
good morning anthony when the irs
designates an organization to be a
charity
some substantial benefits come with it
the group doesn't have to pay federal
taxes or in many cases property taxes
as for donors contributions are tax
deductible now this all adds up to a
certain
credibility for the group and our
investigation found
that credibility is being enjoyed by a
number of groups
you may find troubling
it's been three years since this deadly
scene unfolded at the unite the right
rally in charlottesville virginia
i don't think i will ever not be scared
a day that still haunts liz science who
narrowly escaped injury when a car
deliberately plowed into a crowd of
counter demonstrators
killing one heather heyer i heard
screams i heard this
awful sound but the car almost hit you
yes i don't know how i got out of the
way signs is now the lead plaintiff in a
federal lawsuit against the rally's
organizers
some of whom belong to groups designated
as hate groups
by the southern poverty law center a
civil rights advocacy group
i think charlottesville's and one of the
clearest examples we have
that this extremist violence that we're
witnessing is
organized it's planned it's organized
hate crimes
a cbs news investigation has found
groups that took part in the unite the
right rally are just a few of the 90
white supremacist anti-immigration
anti-muslim
and anti-lgbtq groups registered as
tax-exempt
charities with the irs this also
includes groups like the council of
conservative citizens
which inspired dylan roof to open fire
on a charleston church in 2015.
when we hear that term charitable we
think good phil hackney is a former irs
attorney who worked in the office of the
chief council
overseeing the non-profit sector is
being granted
tax-exempt status is that equivalent to
some form of
governmental endorsement for all
practical purposes
it is a governmental endorsement they're
endorsing hate groups
with dollars during the last decade we
discovered these 90
tax-exempt groups have received more
than a billion dollars
in tax-deductible donations how does
that
affect the average american taxpayer
when you're able to take a charitable
contribution deduction
for certain activity you are taking your
tax dollars out
of the common pot and putting it into
your own private
purpose in this case one of hate
becoming a charitable organization isn't
especially difficult
according to the irs's own data more
than a hundred thousand applications
were filed in 2019
by organizations seeking tax-exempt
status
just 66 were rejected less than 1
tenth of one percent of applications
being denied
tells us what it tells us that uh that
system
is kind of uh i don't want to say a
fraud
but it's not working in fact a group
formally called identity europa
which allegedly incited violence during
the unite the right rally
filed for tax exemption after the fatal
rally
and was approved how much vetting does
the
irs do before granting tax exempt
status to any group today
almost zero after surviving the pulse
nightclub shooting in 2016
brandon wolf became an lgbtq advocate
last year he testified in a
congressional hearing
that the tax code subsidizes hate if the
irs were able to begin to scratch the
surface they would see
that there's a whole lot of things going
wrong here in the past the irs has
revoked tax-exempt status
for things like practicing segregation
or promoting acts of violence
but the irs cannot take away status
solely on the basis of a group's
viewpoint where are the lines
for me i actually think about it on the
other end of the spectrum which is
what happens when these groups actually
do incite violence
who's checking on that the answer today
is no one what happened at pulse
makes this all a deeply personal issue
for you yeah
when you choose to write hate a blank
check in the united states of america
instead of
exercising oversight over it you get
communities torn apart
you get people grieving and mourning
this is the human cost to hatred
liz science tells us she hopes her
lawsuit will hold unite the right rally
organizers
accountable for carrying out violence
she believes was premeditated
in court papers identity europa says it
is not to blame for the actions of the
driver
now we reached out to the irs for
comment but it has yet to respond
to our request tony wow jim very
interested to hear what the irs has to
say if they eventually get back to you
because a hundred thousand applications
for tax-exempt status and they only
rejected 60-something of them
something's not right here all right jim
numbers
yeah thank you very much eye-opening
report